[Musique]
beaucoup écrin qu'est ce que tu cherches
chercher le gain pour jouer au foot avec
mon nom veut bien si tu veux waouh
oui mais non et pourquoi vous êtes des
filles ça change quoi au défi ça joue
pas au foot mais tu viens à quelle
époque les filles au ciel je vous fous
tu connais bien mais gagnera bien banon
quoi tu connais pas megan rapinoe mais
c'est une joueuse de foot américain et
si le jeu de foot remettra connue elle
est américaine mais elle joue à l'ol à
36 ans elle a déjà conclu plein de
choses avec son club ils ont remporté la
coupe de france 2013 avec les états unis
et pour remporter la coupe du monde 2015
et 2019 elle a même gagné une médaille
d'or aux jo 2021 et une de bronze aux jo
2012 et puis quand même mais a reçu le
ballon d'or 2010 9 ans exactement et en
plus d'être une excellente sportive elle
est aussi engagée dans des causes
politiques et civiques comme celle des
lgbt
avant je veux sans
jonathan
harnes et en poésie